in four weeks I'm so glad you guys made
it shield is back on earth the world as
we know it has come to an end
their time is up every local PD is our
picture we're not just wanted but most
wanted
your orders kill them
Kameron guest stars when Marvel's agents
of shield returns all new Friday March
2nd on ABC hey guys so I know I've been
promising you some announcements for a
while and I'm so excited because I
finally get to tell you about one that
I've been waiting to tell you forever
what's up hey everybody as promised this
is my agents of shield video we've
finally found out what's going on this
season with the cracking of the world
what's going on with all the
time-traveling who dove Camryn's
character is what's going on with the
hundredth episode they just went on
break they're basically sitting out the
Olympics and then they'll come back for
episode 11 episode 12 is gonna be the
hundredth episode starting with the
biggest stuff first world breaker Hulk
quake how did she destroy the world why
does everybody think that she destroyed
the world and why does it keep happening
because we found out that they're in a
time loop so they keep trying different
things but each time the outcome is the
same the world keeps getting destroyed
no matter how many different ways they
changed their plan when they go back to
the past around episode 7 episode 8 we
got all the clues we needed to know how
it happened but we didn't know why so
there was a really messed up yo-yo
twister in the episode where yo-yo runs
into herself a version of herself that
had been too heated so many times that
she gone crazy
remember Coulson had that reference like
I've been brought back to life before to
you go a little bit nuts but you learn
to deal with it this version of yo-yo
told us that the reason why the world
keeps getting destroyed is is because
they keep trying to save Coulson he's
dying
you need to let him die then they
flashed a Coulson and there's this
disease spreading on his chest
so Coulson himself is kind of a metaphor
for the show there's a meta thing going
on here in the antagonists of the past
or that military facility the trap fits
the footage and the clues that we've
gotten so far imply that there's the
other piece of the puzzle like obviously
shield gets into a fight something
happens the world gets cracked apart so
I'll say yes I do think that quake is an
important reason for why the world gets
quaked apart but I think that she's only
half of the equation I think you know Q
back to episode 7 8 we found at the Kree
we're using gravitonium to create
artificial gravity on the lighthouse in
outer space
I think I know how they're creating
artificial gravity for the station
unless I'm mistaken and I hope I are
[Music]
so what's probably happening is is
because that prison facility that they
had fits at where they're traveling back
to has all this old shield gear they
have all these secret things it's
basically like a secret prison facility
they're also probably keeping graviton
trapped down there so it's probably
quake Plus graviton equals breaking the
world apart because she's not strong
enough to do it by herself
but gravitonium is incredibly powerful
and a lot of people may have forgotten
that it's actually alive like it's a
person graviton they got turned into
gravitonium
[Music]
so there's probably something really
dumb that these military people try to
do to stop the shield agents and then
that causes the world to get quake to
part like they probably try to use
gravitonium or there's some catastrophic
reaction but maybe it only makes things
worse
either way quake plus gravitonium equals
world getting cracked apart but here is
where we get into the spider-gwen up at
all we finally found out who dove
Cameron is playing that trailer at the
beginning of this obviously tells you
that she's gonna debut in the next
episode if you couldn't tell what they
were implying she's the person wearing
that mask because for the most part she
is Marvel's version of spider-gwen in
all the animated series there's even a
brand new secret warrior style cartoon
featuring dub Cameron playing
spider-gwen and Chloe Bennett playing an
animated version of quake with a bunch
of other characters it's kind of like
forces of Destiny that Star Wars is
doing right now it's one of those types
of shows but they've actually already
revealed that she's playing the daughter
of the military person that's running
this facility so this woman
interrogating Fitz way back in episode 5
she's playing her daughter so it sounds
like she's gonna be playing the type of
character she normally plays she's on
that Disney TV show where she basically
plays the daughter of one of the Disney
villains so think of it in that context
like if you know anything about dove
Cameron yes she plays evilish characters
but she's a relatively good person so
she'll probably wind up trying to help
out the agents of shield through the
course of the season but I do believe
that she's actually a pretty big
character in the back half of the season
so when she debuts in episode 11
she'll be in most of the episodes for
the rest of the season but like I said
they come back episode 11 of camera and
debuts episode 12 is the hundredth
episode they didn't reveal what the plot
of that is going to be but if you
remember arrows hundredth episode it was
meant to be this a love letter to the
fans they did a version of It's a
Wonderful Life with the arrow characters
they might do something similar with the
agents of shield characters where they
try to tie things back to the Avengers
because infinity war is going to be
happening a little while after the
episode airs but also going all the way
back to the original first episodes on
agents of shield so just expect them to
have lots of references and easter eggs
from all across the show's history and I
wouldn't be surprised if Ghost Rider
popped up but just in general
hundredth episodes tend to be love
letters to the fans so if you're a big
fan of the TV show they'll have all
kinds of stuff that you'll probably love
but as for episode 10 cliffhanger there
were a lot of things that they left
hanging like they went back into the
past but it seemed like deke Enoch in
Flint were all left in the future what's
going to happen well the thing about
that is that the actor that plays deke
has been showing up on Chloe Bennett's
Instagram live streams lately and
they're way ahead in the filming
schedule
they've already filmed episode 12 13 14
15 like they're way down the road so
that means that he probably comes back
at some point but we don't know how that
is if he comes back into the past or if
they go back into the future something
crazy happens and somehow he comes back
to the show that also means that Flint
will probably come back too because
there was this whole thing in the last
couple of episodes where they start
referencing these people's parents so
you remember that because we got a shot
of the time loops in the past couple of
episodes that they lived on the
lighthouse for a long time so what's
probably going to happen is we'll find
out that deke in Flint or the
descendants of people on the agents of
shield team like early theory is as the
d k-- is probably the descendant of Fitz
and Simmons because he keeps talking
about his dad but we never see his dad I
think because it'll either be Fitz his
son or he'll be Fitz his grandson just
because they're like seventy two years
in the future so you do the math on that
it would be easier to explain them as
the grandchildren of the agents of
shield people in Flint might wind up
being the grandson of yo-yo and Mack it
just seems like that's the direction
they're headed with that but his early
prediction that some of the characters
that we met and got to know in the
future will wind up being related to the
characters on our team so just post all
your theories about that in the comments
and the really good news is I found out
when we're probably going to get Titans
episodes this is all in the DC Universe
so I'll talk about it more during a
separate video but I got a little more
information about when Titans is coming
how is going to drop and Young Justice
season 3 so all really really good news
but I'll talk about that when I post my
wally west flash legends of tomorrow
video later today so that should post in
a couple hours but if you didn't see my
last infinity war video there is a new
round of that Infinity Gauntlet giveaway
going on now obviously whole bunch of
Super Bowl trailers dropping tomorrow
and
Monday so if you haven't already make
sure you subscribe to get everything
I'll try to do as many videos as
possible but there's a lot of stuff that
drops around the Superbowl so like
there's no way I'm gonna be able to do
everything so there's something that you
really want me to do a video about just
let me know either on Twitter or in the
comments this is somewhere on one of my
social accounts but click here for brand
new infinity war and click here for
brand new flash thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]